I'M THE DEVILS, I'M GETTING TO
THE NET, GETTING SETH
JARVIS. BY ANDRE
SVECHNIKOV AND IT'S CAROLINA
RIPS IT AT THE NET.
IT WAS
SHOOTS, HE SCORES.
IN COLE FOR A  SKATES OF
NICO THROUGH A MAZE OF
TRYING TO GET IN THE NET.
SCORED.
MIDAIR.
THE MIDAIR.
GOOD POSITION
SCORE!
RYAN LED IT, BASTIAN IN FRONT.
THE DEVILS HAVE TIEDLINE.
TIPPED IN FRONT BY PLUS YEARS.
AS SKILLED LEIVO ON THE RUSH FOD
ON THE PUCK HAS JONSSON DO?
La FOR THE THIRD TIME
IN THE
FINDS IT WIDID
CARRIED AHEAD, STEPAN FOR POKED.
ENDS UP BEING AY.
PRESSURE BY THE DEVILS, HAD
JACK HUGHES FILLING THE LANE AND
THEN GET THE PUCK TO THEND TO G.
SEVERSON.
HUGHES AT THE CIRCLE.
RIPS THAT WRIST SHOT OVER THEHEF